the Joe Rogan experience and that's why
if you are truly left-leaning
and if you truly care about getting a
left-leaning government in power you
don't need to get make about class again
because this is one of the reason why
I'd like to Tanya I'm honored her to be
posh and rich you know because they're
so rich these peoples predominantly
they've got so much money and they said
you have real problems this is not what
you can't Center it on you like you're
not worried about man spreading like
it's serious like who worries about that
so like someone on the poverty line
doesn't care about this stuff they don't
care about being represented by the skin
color of say like you know some poor
working-class mother who can't afford
anything isn't gonna care that Hillary
Clinton's in the White House she's not
gonna think over that's okay then I'm
represented that's great well some of
them would someone like it because it'll
make them feel like a woman can get by I
get that and get through that's the
aspirational message that it sends I
think that's fine but you're still stuck
on the poverty line with nothing you
know and it's like poor black Americans
didn't do very well under Obama it
this stuff is tokenism when what you
should be doing sort of directing at
inequality and it's but it's a it's a
big problem both here and in the UK you
know we we've got a left movement I mean
we saw it with brexit you know library
the reason why so many working-class
people voted a bit for bricks and indeed
voted against labor in the last election
is because they're not being they're not
no one's looking out for their interests
right they're worried about other things
like like like you say man spreading
mansplaining like a toxic masculinity
man spoilers ask was just explaining if
you're a man if you correct someone and
they're incorrect in you're a man but
what are their rounds bleeding well then
you're still mansplaining
well that's not how we can't live like
that I can't I can't live like that I
can't um where does it go does it become
a religious war are we in a holy war for
wellness I know but I don't have to I
don't want to have to check the contents
of someone's underwear every time I have
a discussion with them you know I do it
like I don't want to make those
judgments on that well you need to
understand and check yourself because
the contents of someone's underwear does
not mean that that's the gender in which
their day doesn't you piece of [ __ ] I
know I already [ __ ] it up
that's it wait I don't know I don't know
gonna cancel yourself now you should
well I've already been cancelled
probably I don't know that might be a
good example and that might be good idea
maybe titania gets cancelled maybe I
should find a way to camp out yes
because she probably messes up sometimes
well once we will find out that titania
is actually a man yeah well you know
what I'll do it because I just it's
funny you mentioned the the transgender
child cuz I've just written a book as
her as aimed at children right because
of that have you seen this we've seen
this is the woke children's books right
yes I made a joke about one feminist
baby she's got a bullhorn feminist baby
but a bit a bit bullhorn as a feminist
need a bullhorn
oh yeah Jesus Christ she's screaming
about issues she's a baby
yeah but she needs to be heard don't
silence the truth look at that feminist
babe I enter a voice her voice is in a
born right there we go mee-mah if she's
a feminist why is she wearing [ __ ]
makeup when she's a baby that's just
rude
yeah that's rude because that's the
goddamn patriarchy that's socializing
young babies to be sex objects to Christ
how does even know what a boy or a girl
is how many of these are baby these look
like they're aimed very much at very
young kids as well like so yeah like
well it's name it's aimed at the mothers
and fathers very young kids who want to
let everybody know their work and they
probably only pulled them out when
people come over the house I mean but
this is this is you scraping the
surfaces so one of the big selling books
was good night stories for rebel girls
which is like each chapters about a
major feminist icon that's aimed at
young kids there's one called
see is for consent that's aimed at very
young kids there's one called the little
girl who gave zero [ __ ]
right this this sort of you know it's
funny I look at this stuff I think this
is such flagrant indoctrination you're
not even hiding it anymore
right if there's nothing subtle about
this you know yeah so like I thought so
I've written a book as to Tanya and
she's trying to it's called my first
little book of intersectional activism
right because she can't get it right she
talks to kids like they're just
sociology so something she can't get it
right which is which is fun and she said
to them you know your parents hate you
you know you should get you should ditch
them like
I think that's the way to do it well
that's what every cult does yeah exactly
one of the things that cults do one of
the hallmarks of cults is they try to
separate you from your parents yeah or
if you get the kids young then you can
you can get their minds eventually so
maybe that's is that the solution trying
to trying to make sure it doesn't get I
don't know young maybe I don't know if
there is a solution I think there are
patterns that always exist and religions
pop up like why Christianity why
Mormonism why Islam why you know what
what causes these patterns these
ideological patterns what causes them
what causes them to take hold what
causes them to their followers to become
rabid I don't know what it is but they
exist and they exist they have existed
throughout history there's the literally
hundreds of them is it a need for
purpose is it a need to feel that you
are the one person in the tree it's it's
certainly there's instincts that we all
have to be a part of a group and to be
accepted as a part of a group and one of
the ways that you show that you're a
part of that group is by rigidly
adhering to the doctrine
[Applause]